what am i doing I'll tell you what I'm
doing a lot of people would call it ego
searching searching your name on search
Twitter and Google Blog search please
pay attention where I am in Google where
is the most important place in Google in
my opinion the blog search you got to go
to the more and you got to go to the
blogs and then you gotta search your
name or your business or your product
and this is not ego searching my friends
what this is is a very smart way to care
because doesn't it come down to
listening isn't that the key in
relationships let me help you it is and
how can you listen in a social media
world well I'll tell you how by using
search functionality and you got to
search all kinds of ways for example
you'll notice on Google Mott right here
you'll notice it says did you mean
vaynerchuk I did but of course I've got
to spell it with a ck because that's how
many people spell my name that way
probably half cuz Boehner trucks one
fucked-up name now here is what's up you
need to care you need to search and you
need to engage imagine a world where you
said wow this tylenol is really making
my tummy feel better and somebody from
tylenol actually direct messaged you and
said thank you and let me send you
another free bottle paying attention to
what people are saying about you
thinking or caring about is what is the
most imperative factor in building a
business whether it's about a personal
brand like yourself or a product or a
business name like a store whatever it
may be what you've got to realize is
listening is the key now why are a lot
of companies not doing it because it's
hard i'm sitting here rocking the Chaka
Khan searching my name four hours a day
every day every month every year because
I care about the people that are engaged
in my content whether that's from a
store standpoint from a personal brand
standpoint marketing and consulting wine
reviewing whatever it is it comes down
to caring people and way too many people
just don't care or it's just too hard
you know why it's hard
because it takes a lot of this it takes
a crap load of time and people don't
have that right you're spending it on
more important things what's more
important than reading your email and
paying attention to what people are
saying about you because if you do
something wrong you can find it and fix
it and that's what people care about you
know you win you care